I got 10,000 people to promote my next
book, $100 million leads, absolutely
free. And to give you a visual of that,
that's like an entire stadium full of
people promoting your thing. And now
imagine those people leaving that
stadium and then entering their own
individual stadiums and shouting, being
like, go check this thing out. And the
best part is it's absolutely free. I was
thinking to myself like, what would be
the craziest way that I could launch
this book to make a big fanfare about
it? Because my first book, $100 million
offers, was all about making a crazy
offer to people, as in making an offer
so good people feel stupid saying no.
And I tried to make the book a meta
example of the concept within the book.
I talk about having elements to enhance
the offer, having a big price to value
discrepancy. And so I offer the book for
99 cents, but included a course, which
most people would charge thousands of
dollars for absolutely free without even
asking people to opt in for it. All of
this was just to demonstrate the value
equation, which was the core concept of
that book. Now, my $100 million leads
book is a different book. It's about
advertising in order to get leads. And
so I was like, "Okay, well, if I wanted
to demonstrate all the concepts in that
book, I'd have to do something totally
different than how I did with offers."
And so with this, I was like, "Well, how
do I show that I can get lots of leads
with a book?" And so I was like, I'm
going to hold a big book event. So I'm
going to hold a book launch event. It's
be virtual and it's going to be free and
everyone's invited. And I'm going to see
how many people I can get to this thing.
And I'm not going to do it the way I
could do it, which would just be like I
could post on my social media. I
probably get plenty of people to go. I
wanted to use every single one of the
methods I talk about in the book to
promote the book itself. And one of
those methods is called affiliate
marketing. And so the way that I
actually did this in the real world was
that we created an affiliate optin,
which is just put your name, your email,
your phone number, and then what we
would give them is a unique URL. So a
custom link that if someone clicked
their link, it would take them to the
leads opt-in page for the event, but it
would be tracked back to them. And then
the top 10 affiliates, I said I would
hop on a live Q&A call with their
audience if they won. and they were in
the top 10. Anyone who got at least 10
people to show up to the event, I would
give two bonus chapters for my book that
I'm not going to release with the book
as an added benefit. And if you think
about this, it's because I want to
incentivize the highest affiliates to
promote the most and be competitive, but
I don't want somebody who has like a 100
person email list to think, oh, I'm
never going to win that. Why bother?
Well, there's also a prize that everyone
can win. There's scarcity at the top,
but then just a tiny hurdle for
everyone, which is actually one of the
strategies I talk about when creating an
affiliate compensation system, because
it actually works the same way. Whether
you're promoting an event or supplements
or widgets or services, it all works the
same way. So, inside this video, I'm
going to talk about who to pick to
affiliate with, how to onboard them
properly, and set expectations, how to
get them to start advertising, and how
to keep them advertising along the way,
and a little bonus of how to structure
that offer. All right. So, the first
thing that you have to figure out when
you're creating an affiliate strategy or
an influencer strategy is who is the
ideal affiliate. One of the more
advanced advertising strategies is that
you actually have two customers. Now,
you have your affiliate avatar and then
you have your customer avatar. So, now
it means that you have to deliver to two
types of people rather than one. And
that's where it gets more complicated if
you're starting out. That being said,
there's different ways of doing this in
different industries. For example, if
I'm a brick-and-mortar business, my
affiliate strategy is, let's say I'm a a
massage person, I could then go and say,
"Okay, what are all the big businesses
in the area?" and say, "Okay, these guys
hire 10 new employees a week. It's a big
corporation." I say, "Hey, Mr.
Corporation, I want to give each of your
new employees two free massages on the
house. Here's a coupon. You can give it
to them in their new employee packet."
Why would that business say no to giving
their employees some sort of treat? And
for me, I'm happy to just get new
customers. And if I make that
partnership now with 10 or 100
companies, then I'm going to be able to
fill up my books. And how much did that
cost me in advertising? Literally only
the effort to reach out to them and make
the ask. All right? And so you have with
an affiliate strategy two levels of
offers. What's the offer you're going to
make them? And then what's the offer
they're going to make on your behalf to
their customers, right? And so the two
free massages is my c is my offer to
their customer, which in this place is
an employee, which totally underrated
strategy because they'll never see you
as competition. But then also, why am I
going to make this offer to the
employer? The offer to them is your
employees will like you more and have a
better onboarding experience and be
distressed by having this thing and
you'll be perceived as a more caring
employer. That's the offer. I don't need
to like incentivize them and pay them or
do anything like that because it's in
their best interest. To the same degree,
if I'm still that massage therapist, I
might go to a chiropractor and say,
"Hey, some of your people get their
backs cracked and they probably need
someone to massage." Anybody who gets
their back cracked with you, I'll give
them a massage on the house. And then
all of a sudden, that chiropractor who
gets 50 new patients a month, we'll send
you a certain percentage of those
patients. Now, you could also even pay
them on top of that to further
incentivize them. But typically, if you
do a really good job and you establish a
relationship, they'll start doing that.
And if you're really smart about it,
you'll start referring them business,
too. And then that is where you really
start the machine going. That's a
brick-and-mortar example. An influencer
example is probably what most people are
used to, which is like, "Hey, use my
discount code for 10% off." And then the
influencer gets some kickback. Now,
sometimes that's just a straight
endorsement. You pay them to post, which
is much more like paid advertising, or
you do some sort of split based on what
they bring you, which is much closer to
affiliate advertising, which is what I'm
talking about. A third version of this
is the main way that I use to market
this book, which is affiliate marketing,
which is much more common in the
internet marketing world. This covers a
huge amount of people who have lists and
audiences that they have trust with.
What you have to do is say, "Hey, you
will gain trust with your audience." The
trade is that sometimes they do lose
trust with their audience, which is why
people pay to get affiliates.
Ultimately, your brand matters a lot
with why they would trust their
customers and their goodwill with you.
And so the reason in my opinion that the
book launch, which is not here, but
pretend I have my book right here, has
gone well using the strategy is that
many people in my audience trust that
I'm going to overd deliver, which I
absolutely am, to their audience. And so
their audience will then associate the
value they get from me with them. And so
it's almost like them getting free
goodwill by promoting my stuff, right?
And that's what you want. The crazy part
about the affiliate strategy that I'm
going to outline for you is that I
actually have zero financial incentive,
which is not common. Most of the time if
you go to a social media, you know, you
get some influencer and you're like,
"Hey, will you promote my supplement
brand?" They're like, "Well, what's my
split?" Right? Because they're like,
"I'm going to be taking some goodwill
out of my audience, so I need to be
compensated for that." But if you have
such goodwill, you might do it for free
if you actually thought that it was
good. I mean, think about when a friend
of yours is like, "Hey, what pair of
shoes are those?" You're like, "Oh, I
love these shoes, or I love this bag,"
or whatever it is. You're being an
affiliate just in a micro with your
micro influence to that business. And
you do it because you feel like you will
actually gain in relational capital
because that person will go buy the
shoes, use the shoes, love the shoes,
tell you about it, associate with you.
That's why you do it. The affiliate
strategy that I outlined for my process
was simple. I have two layers of
affiliates. And I think this is useful
for anyone when you're thinking about
your products or your business is that
I've got my super affiliate level and
then I've got regular affiliates. The
key difference is that I like to have
two polar opposite strategies. The
people who are super affiliates have big
audiences and they tend to be
competitive, more status driven, etc.
And so I want to align what they want,
which is status, with what I want, which
is people. What I decided to do was say,
"Hey," and this is going to be pretty
key, and I haven't I haven't explained
this publicly yet, so you know, enjoy. I
said the top 10 will get an AMA live
with me to their audience. Now, here's
why this is unique and different. One, I
have a very small supply of time, like I
don't speak in public very much. I think
in the last year of companies that I
don't own, I've done one speech. I try
and limit my supply of time that I'm
available to other people's audiences.
Imagine you're now in the audience of
this super affiliate and he says, "Hey,
register for this book event." Now, if
I'm the customer or I'm that person's
audience, I think, what's in it for me?
Why don't I just go to Alex's thing
rather than clicking your link? Or why
do I click your link for someone else's?
Well, here's why. This benefits them.
So, if I'm the affiliate, I say, "Hey,
click my link so that our community can
have the prize rather than me saying,
"Hey, the top 10 affiliates get
supercars." Right? Because why does that
benefit their audience? Because if I did
if I did it exactly that, hey, let me
help me win my contest, that is
withdrawing from their audience. But if
I do it this way, then I can say, "Hey,
I actually want to support you in your
audience." And that way when you make
this email to your list, it doesn't cost
you anything. And so that's why I
engineered it this way so that this is
just goodwill they gain and the reason
why is aligned so that their incentive,
my incentive, and the audience's
incentive are all aligned towards the
same outcome, which is to get the click
and to sign up for the event. So,
whenever you're making something for any
affiliate, you want to align all of the
incentives to the greatest degree
possible. Now, when you say, "I'm just
going to pay them," that aligns your
incentive and their incentive, but not
the audience's incentive. And so, the
more aligned incentives you get, the
bigger the outcome. Now, the second
level is regular affiliate. So, if
you're like, "Okay, well, right now I
think the top the top people all have
like a thousand people that they've sent
over to uh the book launch for us." And
so, if you have a,000 total followers,
the likelihood that you're going to send
all thousand is probably pretty low. And
so, you might be like, "Well, why even
bother?" So, you have to answer that
question, which is why I have the second
tier. So, why bother even affiliating to
begin with, why bother even promoting
this? I said, if you get more than 10 to
show up to the event, just 10 people,
and if you have an email list or you
have any following whatsoever, even if
you don't have any of those things, you
just know 10 people who you think it
would be valuable, you don't have to
have any marketing skills to get 10
people to a thing. And the reason you
would do it, remember, aligned
incentives, is that they trust that if I
say, "Hey, this is going to be worth it.
I'm going to deliver on that." And the
reason they might be able or willing to
make that bet is because if I've said it
in the past that it would be worth it,
I've delivered on that. And so to give
you a bit of context, I've only emailed
my list, I think, like three or four
times in the past year. And I've made a
lot of content. We put out 250 a week,
1,000 pieces of content a month. So
12,000 a year, right? Roughly in terms
of pieces of content, and only four
pieces of content that I say, I think
you guys should go check this out. It's
worth the time, right? Not to say I
don't think the other time is worth it,
but if I'm going to make the ask, I want
to make sure that whatever they get is
far in excess. Because let's say every
piece of content 80% of people think
it's good and 20% of people think it's
mid, whatever. Okay? But if I know that
99% of people are going to believe that
it's going to be amazing, then that's
one where I have a low risk of saying,
"Hey, you're going to get more than your
time by doing this or by watching this."
And so from the big picture perspective,
when you're promoting this, you don't
want to like smash everyone all at once
the whole time because then people get
sick of you, right? The best analogy
I've heard from this is something called
whisper tea shout. And I heard this
somewhere at some event and I don't know
who originally came up with it, but I
just love this. You got whisper t-shirt.
And this is really like the three phases
of promoting anything. So whisper is
where you drip itty bit like not even
hints. You're just building
anticipation. And so this is like the
Godzilla scene in the movie theaters
that's just like the foot and it just
says May 2025, right? And so they don't
tell you the plot. There's no character
development. It's just enough to get you
excited. That's all it is. within the
context of this book over the last two
years I've just been sprinkling little
stories of me like oh another day of
writing another like just oh got another
thing I got something good for you like
and I'm just showing just not a lot not
saying what's inside of it not talking
at all about the contents just saying
I'm writing a book and this some and
it's going to be good you guys are going
to love it right and showing the work
because let me give you a quick example
on this is that if I said I spent 2
years making this 10-minute video how
likely would it be that you think that
video was good compared compared to I
said, "Hey, I spent 2 hours on this
10-minute video." You'd probably be way
more likely to watch the 10-minute video
that I spent 2 years working on. And so,
the same thing works with whatever
projects you want to sell. The further
out you can show them that you're
working on this thing, the more they'll
believe that you have invested in it.
And I learned this from an early mentor
of mine. He said, "The key to making it
a big deal is to make it a big deal."
And so, like, it doesn't matter what
you're doing. If you tell people that
something's a big deal, then they will
believe that it's a big deal. And so, I
can't say it more simply than that. And
so if I show you that I've been working
on this for 2 years, then when I say
it's finally ready, people be like,
"Wow, he's worked a long time on this. I
want to check it out." So you build
curiosity here. We transition to the
tease phase. Let me let me walk you
through. So phase one is 6 weeks plus
out. That means like 3 months out, 12
months, 2 years out. You're just
whispering. It's all we're doing here.
Then we get into teasing. So, this is
where you you peel back a corner of the
page and you and you show one page or
you do a reading of a paragraph or you
make videos about some of the content,
right, that's inside the book. Now, you
don't show the whole thing. You just
zoom in on a little bit, just a just a
clip, just a little something something.
So, they're like, "Ooh, now I have a
prediction of what type of value I'm
going to get from this thing." Right?
Now, you're looking at the trailer,
right? That's 30 seconds long that has a
couple dinosaurs running in and out.
You're like, "Ooh, there's there's
action in this." like you get a general
direction of what this movie is going to
be about. This is 6 weeks to 7 days.
Then you transition to shout. Shout is
the last seven days leading up into the
thing. At this point, you're not
whispering. You're not teasing. You're
not hinting. You're like, "This is the
thing. It's going to be awesome. Be
there." And most of this is reminders. A
big part that most people mess up, and
this is what I see a lot of marketers do
overall, is they spend six weeks
shouting, right? People literally get
bored of your thing before before it
even happens cuz you've talked about it
so much, right? So that's number one.
And you want it to be a you want it to
feel like this. It's like intermittent
intermittent more frequent and then you
crescendo up into whatever the event is,
right? And you get big lots of money.
There you go. Right? When we're in the
shout phase, how effective you are at
the shout is actually predicted by
everything you did before that. And so
what happens is most people don't
provide enough value before they say,
"Hey, I've got my thing." Right? And so
what they have to do is they start
having to artificially create value and
increase their content frequency in
order to approximate having provided
value beforehand. And so they try and
provide value and ask and provide value
and ask at the same time. And it just
looks disjointed because they don't have
any goodwill that to withdraw from. And
so then they ask and shout even harder
and louder until eventually no one
listens to them. And you don't want
that. We want to be really careful about
when we're shouting. It is super
effective, but then you burn it out
quickly. And so you want to use it right
here so it leads to the event. During
the whisper and tease phase, and this is
something that uh my brand director and
I, Caleb, had a long discussion about,
which is during these time periods, are
we going to only talk about the book?
It's like, well, no. What about during
the cheese phase? Are we only going to
talk about the book? No. We're going to
still provide value the exact same way
we have been, in the exact same volume
we have been, and then added it on top.
So, think about that. You're like,
"Wait, that sounds like more work." Sure
is.
My team's behind the camera just
sweating.
The idea though is that why would I want
to decrease the value that I'm providing
my audience during the time when I want
to ask them to do something even more.
It's like no, not only do I want to make
sure that I'm providing my regular
value, which is about business content
in general, growing businesses, scaling,
sales, marketing, etc., but then I also
want to talk about the book. And if you
want to be clever with it whenever
you're making your advertisements, cuz
this is an advertisement. If it just
means making other people know about
your stuff, that's what I'm doing,
right? You want to still make sure that
the advertisement itself is still
valuable. Like, who here likes going to
the movie theater and then watching the
trailers? I love watching the trailers
before movie. Like, I'm bummed if I
don't get the first 15 minutes before
the movie. Why? Because they are
valuable. They're entertaining. I like
watching them. And so, there's a reason
they designed them that way. People
share trailers. Why? Cuz it's valuable.
And if you share the trailer, what did
it do? You got more people to find out
about it. Which is why well-designed
advertisements provide value to the
person and let them know about the
thing. That's the magic throughout this
whole process. If you think about value
as this line, this is constant all the
way through. it unch it's unchanging.
All right, so we're providing value the
whole time and then we sprinkle in
whisper whisper. Then we start showing
more details about what they're going to
find out the value that they're going to
get and then we remind we remind we
remind until the event. Meanwhile, still
posting value, still adding to the
audience so that each of these hit.
Because think about this, every day you
have new people who come into your world
and they don't have 2 years of goodwill.
So, I have probably more people coming
into my world right now because so many
more people are are promoting my book
that I actually have to deliver more
value than I ever have because I have so
many new people who are now going to
find out about my stuff. And what a
shame it would be if they enter my world
and then the only thing they have is a
is a smash from me saying, "Go grab
something. Go check out my virtual
event." Right? So, I have to be
delivering in higher amounts because I
have more people than ever who are
seeing your stuff. Right? That's the
idea. And that is the whole concept
between the three-phase attack of
whisper tease shout. And for everyone
who wants to use paid influencers, paid
affiliates, endorsements, I have tons of
money examples, costs and returns, how
to calculate it, how to set what
percentages for what tiers of
affiliates, how to set up multiple
tiers, how much value I put in each one.
I have all of those in all the best
practices that I've used inside of here.
I didn't want to include it in this
video, not cuz I don't want to share it
because I think a lot of people would
get lost in the numbers and you probably
want to read and reread it again in
front of you, which is why it's in the
book. So, if this is interesting and
you're like, man, I would love to find a
way that other businesses could
advertise my stuff on my behalf and do
it for free or do it only after I've
made money so there's no risk to me,
then affiliates are your play. So, let's
talk about the actual mechanics of this.
All right, so for me, because I didn't
have to do payouts, it became
significantly easier for me to get
affiliates. All right? Because
typically, when you have an affiliate,
there's two ways to do it. You can have
paid and unpaid. So, paid affiliates,
you either pay them with money or you
scratch their back, they scratch your
back, right? This is the collab. This is
the I'll promote your thing if you
promote my thing. Now, for me, I don't
feel confident that I could promote a
lot of my affiliate stuff. Just being
really candid because I don't know if
they're necessarily at that level yet or
I wouldn't risk the trust that I have
built with my audience. Just being very
candid. But they're not asking me to do
that. So, that's okay. Now, on the
unpaid side, they have to get other
things. And that's where I'm adding
those extra bonuses in in order to get
them to want to do it. When you have a
paid affiliate, you have to get them to
fill out all these forms, taxes,
so that you can pay them and they can be
seen as uh I don't even remember what it
is. Maybe it's a K1 or a 1099. I don't I
think it's a 1099. They get a 1099 from
your company because they'll have sent
you money and then you have to send them
money back and there's all these forms
you have to have them fill out. Now, the
good thing with this is that if someone
goes to the trouble of doing this, the
likelihood that they want to promote is
significantly higher. So, there are
benefits to this. If I'm in a B2B
business all day long, I want to have a
little bit more friction. I want to
qualify the affiliates. I want to make
sure that they're sending the right
types of people to whatever it is that I
have, especially if I'm selling
services. Now, I have a book which is
delivered without my time. And so, I'm
willing to forgo some of the friction
that I would normally put in with a B2B
business in order to get more scale and
volume in a BTOC scenario. So, for here,
the way the opt-in form worked for our
affiliate uh campaign, if you've if you
want to check it out, you can go to
acquisition.com/affiliate.
And what you'll see is you'll see a
first name, last name, email, phone, and
that's it. and you'll see a button when
they click that the thank you page and
we did it in two ways. The thank you
page has their now custom link that they
can use to promote your thing and they
get an email because sometimes people
lose it or they don't screenshot or
whatever that also has a copy of that.
This sounds like tiny stuff but
sometimes like the extra email or
putting on the thank you page makes a
25% difference in the amount of people
who promote your stuff. And as a side
benefit here, we actually changed the
banner on top of the submit form and
increase the amount of affiliates who
decided to sign up on the optage by 60%.
All right. And so little things can
still make huge differences in the
campaign, which is why I'm sharing these
tiny details with you. Now, when you
want the affiliates to sign up, if you
want volume, you make it easier. If you
want quality, you make it harder. And
the pushpull in business is figuring out
where the sweet spot is for your for
your products at your price point. I'm
going really mass market for a book,
which is considered probably a pretty
cheap thing. All right. And so I can go
all the way on this side. And then I'm
trying to make this as easy as humanly
possible. So like, how long does it take
to sign up to be an affiliate of the
book? 30 seconds. And literally someone
could go 30 seconds and then make a
story on social media and immediately
share it and get leads, right? So I made
it really low time delay. Remember the
value equation. We can still apply it to
every step in this whole process. So the
value is they become an affiliate. The
time delay is 30 seconds. The effort and
sacrifice is they type their stuff in.
And the perceived likely that it works
is they click submit. And if it works,
they're done. Right? So we still apply
the same four variables to every step in
this process to get the most amount of
people to promote your stuff. Now, from
your promotional as aspects, there are
two big promotions that you'll be
running concurrently. Again, remember I
said there's two types of customers.
Well, that means that I'm running
marketing campaigns to the customers who
I want to show up to the event and I'm
also now running campaigns to the
affiliates to remind them to promote the
event, right? Because once you get the
affiliate, that's the easy part. The
hard part is getting them to advertise
your thing. And so this is where
reminders, reachouts, like tokens,
here's Starbucks, just getting them
engaged, messaging them to remind them
to keep doing it. Because the thing is
is if they promote it once, it'll help a
little bit. But if they promote it
consistently throughout the whole time,
they're all in. And the depth that you
will get with their audience, because
their audience will see that they are
bought in, you will carry on some of
that trust when you make your offer for
whatever it is. So one of the important
things is that I have a big list of
people who going to this event. And so I
said, "Hey, it would mean the world to
me if you shared this event with your
audience." So I sent two emails to that
big list. And from those two emails, we
got 9,000 people to say they wanted to
register. Now, I shared it on my story
and I shared in other places, but the
majority of that came from my email list
who decided to become affiliates and
promote it to their audiences. Here's a
mistake that a lot of people make is
that they will then keep messaging the
audience that's supposed to show up to
the event to promote the event and then
they lose goodwill in that audience. And
so I opt to do two max three
advertisements over the entire length of
whatever your campaign is to let them
know that the opportunity exists. And
even within those messages, I assume
that my customers are going to be the
vast majority of people are going to
read this. So be smart about what you're
saying. Don't be like, "Oh man, we're
going to sell a shitload of books here."
Right? Like you can't say that, right?
Like because your customers are like,
"That's how he sees me." Right? You
don't want that. And so the idea is like
this is going to be an amazing event.
like you want to continue to edify the
event and follow the same messaging
buckets that you would about the main
thing, but then tie in the why it ties
to the mission for them to also support
you and the whole cause overall. And so
for us, we sent two emails that created
9,000. And then once they get onto that
list, then they've given you permission
to give them way more information. But
even then, I tend to just because
probably my communication style in
general, I tend to communicate
thoroughly, but not as frequently. Like
some people want to email every day.
That's not my vibe. And so every week
and we set the expectation up front. you
will get two emails a week from me from
now until the day of the thing. And that
way they can think, okay, there's five
weeks. I'm going to get 10 emails from
Done. And then what do I do when I make
my promises? I keep my promises. And so
I say, the first email is going to be
more content that you can then use
because I'm going to give them stuff in
real time. Now, what did we do with the
content? I told you I gave them the
black book. Was there any more stuff? Of
course there was. But I didn't give it
up front because I knew that everybody
was going to take that stuff because now
that's their insider intel that shows
that they have more inside knowledge
than anyone else does, which is why
people click their link and also gives
them stronger brand association. But
then 3 weeks in, I'm going to give them
another big packet of stuff that they
can then use so that I can guarantee
that their ads don't get stale as they
promote my thing, just like I would for
myself. So I would not give them that
same advantage cuz I want them to
promote it and I want it to work. Two
emails a week, one with the content and
the other with the update of where they
stand. Cuz a lot of people are like,
well, where am I? How many do I have?
And this is the part that a lot of
people don't get is that you have to
give them tracking back. Now, the more
advanced you are as an affiliate
marketer and people who manage networks
of affiliates, sometimes you need to
have back-end tie-ins so they can get
pixel fires and all sorts of stuff. Now,
for me, because of the nature of this
event, I didn't mess with any of that
cuz I wanted to make it very easy, very
light lift for all the affiliates. And I
wanted to be more on goodwill and if
they're aligned with the cause more than
because they're trying to get a
paycheck. The right affiliates are also
stoked about the thing, right? And this
is a piece that I think a lot of people
miss when they do this is they're like,
if you just try to get people for the
money, then it means you've hired
mercenaries. If you get people for the
cause, you've hired missionaries, right?
And you want missionaries, not
mercenaries, because mercenaries will
just go to the next person who has the
highest bidder. And then you basically
have a reverse race to the bottom. You
have a race to the top in terms of how
much you're willing to pay them to
promote your thing, which is not a type
of business that I want to be in. And so
I'd rather say, hey, you're not going to
get anything, but you're going to get
all this goodwill. And if you're
associated with that or you want to
associate with that, then here's a way
to do it that's fast and easy. And so we
provide them even more value than the
people who are on the list in their
sphere. Like it's not it's more value,
it's different value that they would
find interesting. like me explaining how
I'm doing this affiliate thing is
valuable for them so that they can use
it on their own stuff because these are
all marketers and promoters in their own
right have their own businesses and so
for them half the value is seeing what
I'm doing behind the scenes so that they
can employ it themselves. I'll bet you a
third of the list of the 9,000 are just
want to see what I'm doing and aren't
even planning to promote it at all and
that's okay. I'm fine with that. All
right, but by the way, if you are going
to promote, go promote. The the TLDDR
here is provide value to them just like
you would a customer. Give them stats of
where they're at. Be consistent with
whatever promises you make. be upfront
about the expectations that you have of
them and what expectations they can have
of you and then stick to those. And then
the last week, the last few days, a
couple extra reminders and then you're
on. And then after that, you announce
the winners and you give them the prizes
that you promised. And when you
choreograph all that together, you might
be like, "Man, that's a lot of work."
Well, yeah, but so is so valuable is
having 9,000 other people promoting your
stuff for you. Because if you think
about it, at the end of the day, there's
two people who can promote what you
have. You and other people. And there
are more of them than there are of you.
There's a lot of people in the world and
there's a lot of people who don't know
who you are. And so if you can find a
way to make it a win-win win, you unlock
as much traffic as you want for whatever
it is you're trying to sell. And so the
win-win-win, cuz I'm going to say this
again, I think it's important, is that
you have to win, the affiliate has to
win, and most importantly, their
audience has to win. And if you can if
you can show them that their audience
wins by them associating with you, you
will unlock the doors to as much
promotion as you want. And the coolest
part, and I'm saying this again, is that
this is absolutely free. Anyone can do
this. And all you do is you lead with
value. And you have to remember that you
now have two customers. You have your
affiliates that you have to make offers
to and deliver on and market to and
provide value to. And you have the
customers, yours and their customers
that you now have to deliver on. And I
will tell you this, the standards that
the affiliates will have for how you
treat their customers will be even
higher than how you treat your
customers. And the main thing is is
because everybody thinks they treat
their customers better than they really
do. And so they expect anyone else to
treat them with the utmost respect and
care. Having affiliates forces you to
raise your own standards for how you how
good you are at messaging and
advertising in general, which is one of
the things I kind of like about it
because it gives me a little bit more
pressure to keep overd delivering. And I
will tell you that there are a couple
things that I made, a couple tweaks that
I made to how we're promoting the book
that I only made after some of my
closest friends were like, "Dude, I'm
going to be pushing this to my whole
audience." And I was like, "I need to
say this differently. I need to word
this differently." and these tiny tweaks
that I think will give huge out huge
outcomes for us and them, but I wouldn't
have done if I didn't have that next
level of pressure. And so that is the
complete behindthe-scenes affiliate
guide of how I promoted this book, $100
million leads. And maybe by the time you
see this, we'll be at 10,000. And real
quick, if you have an audience that's
big or small, and you've enjoyed the
content or you enjoyed the last book and
you think that your audience or your
friends would enjoy the next book, then
you can go register and actually promote
it at acquisition.com/affiliate.
And there's no financial incentive. And
you can tell your audience that you have
no financial incentive for doing it. And
the idea is that if they click your
link, you might enter to win. But I
forgot to say the last little secret,
which is that if you just get over 10
people to the event, I'll give you two
bonus chapters that I'm not going to
release in the book just for every
single person who brings 10 people to
the event because it means so much to me
that I didn't put the value in the book
just to give it to you guys because I
knew that I wanted this to be special
and I wanted to demonstrate what I say
in the book in real life. And now that
you understand the affiliate strategy
that I'm using to promote $100 million
leads, here is the next video for making
you more dollars.